yes okay this isn't my question but
um
why should
it's a question on modesty why should
women wear skirts and dresses and can
you show from the Bible and also Spirit
of property as well why should women
wear skirts and dresses
all right
modesty
is a is a difficult concept to Define in
precise terms because modesty varies
from culture to culture
I've been to India on a couple of
occasions and the Indian leading me
coming to church and all of this is
exposed
but that's modest in India
that's not bodice in Little Rock are you
following me
so don't tell me I saw a woman no no
that's modest in India I was in Ghana
and there was a guy on the pulpit he
seemed to be wrapped in a bed sheet it
wasn't a bed sheet but it looked just
wrapped this around and and hit most of
this out and it was but that's modest in
Ghana
and so modesty depends on where you are
but there is a unifying theme regarding
modesty and that theme is the holy
spirit of God
the spirit of God will guide and you see
the church cannot provide microscopic
guidance in every little detail of the
believer's life there must be room for
the spirit of God to say don't do that
don't do that don't do that
and so what I recommend to you is you
ask
last night I said everything must be
done for the glory of God
before you dress
before you buy us outfit dress pants
whatever shoes before you go to the
barber for a hairstyle you ladies meant
to
ask God
Father Is This For Your Glory
if it's not
keep waiting for the spirit to convict
you I was in Namibia
and I was talking to young people one
Sunday morning
And I stress the principle of for the
glory of God without exception where you
dress your hair your shoes your
relationships your food every single
thing will this glorify God and it was a
young lady present
she had a hairstyle
I mean this thing was huge I like to
call it an Eagles Nest sitting on her
head that's the way it looked
and I said okay all right next morning I
was doing one-to-one counseling and she
came and I didn't recognize it
she said you recognized me I said no she
said I am the lady who had this oh I
said what happened she said as I
listened to you
I was convicted because I realized I did
not make this choice for the glory of
God I was simply following fashion and
she cut it off the very day
went off into canvassing I mean it's
just a conviction on hairstyle took her
into canvassing and medical missionary
work she was convicted I was in Bermuda
conducting a week of prayer and this guy
came every day he's a Rastafarian
he has these dreadlocks and you know and
this
okay
Jesus died for the whole world not just
for people who sure they don't know him
and so he came he came
the Sabbath morning for baptism he went
to the back of the church and came back
and nobody recognized him he had brought
his scissors to church with him
something in the week of break convicted
this man he cut the whole thing off
because he knew honestly that this was
not for God's glory let me tell you
what's missing in many of our decisions
honesty we will not be honest with
ourselves I chose that shoe because I
want to look good I was not thinking of
God's glory at all
let me tell you this guaranteed if you
ask first is this for the glory of God
your choices will change all of this
about modesty modesty will be directed
by the spirit of God as you give
yourself to Christ and allow him to
direct your choices that is a tie or
I'm not an example of anything but let
me tell you
because I travel a lot
I'm always on planes
eloit said to the preacher when the
preachers Get Up In a Pulpit she said
wear a dark suit
because you make an effect even before
you open your mouth
you have an effect on people she said
let the effect be positive by the way
you look and all experts in Psychology
will agree with that now and so I would
ask God father what tie should I wear
on the plane
literally
has my wife which tie
I've stood in a bathroom with two or
three times in my face said Father which
one I've actually had Ties on and then
taking them off because the spirit said
not that one this one
that time may turn somebody off
literally
and so I ask
when I began doing that you will not
believe the thing the experiences I've
had when I started asking God what shirt
to wear
and what I
and what suit
I would ask him
now I can't say I Heard a Voice but you
get impressions
I was a living I think it was Nigeria
these things actually began happening to
me
and I'm coming down with my little
handbag dressed
and the immigration guy saw me coming he
said come Bishop come
so I said to him when I got to the desk
why do you call me Bishop he said it's
obvious you're preacher I said why'd you
say that he said the anointing is all
over you
and he took off his cap he said bless me
and so I dropped a blessing on him
I was in South Africa these things began
to happen and I was coming again through
security and the guy said to me come
preacher
when I got to him I said why do you call
me please he said but you look like one
I said okay then I went to another
officer a little further down because
you have multiple Security checks he
said come come preacher he didn't hear
my first interaction I said why do you
call me preacher he said but you look
like one I said okay I was another trip
to South Africa I was going to a canvas
a University campus to preach the
students University of what is Rand
outside Johannesburg or in Johannesburg
we were driving my driver and I and I
told him pull him by that gas station I
wanted some gum you know Americans love
chewing gum
so he pulled in and I went to one little
store like a 7-Eleven and I said do you
have gum she said uh yes she gave me the
gum I said you have juice she said no
so I got the juice
no I asked her for juice first for juice
she went to get the juice and the juice
was
right next to the liquor
so I said uh you were close to the
liquor section is that you she said I
would never give you liquor I said why
not she said you're a preacher
I said how do you know that she said
it's obvious you're a preacher
I went to the next door right next door
to get the gum
the guy said come Bishop so I'm getting
irritated now why do you call me that he
said but you look like one
all this began to happen when I
literally began to ask God what I
what shirt
what suit
I'm not joking what am I telling you ask
God
when you stand in front of those dresses
which one should I pick
forget Beyonce ask God
which one should I pick forget little
Naz ask God what shirt should I buy you
know forget whomever asked God how
should I fix my hair ask him I'm telling
you if you listen he'll tell you not
that
not that I've seen women in church on
high heels so high
I said Lord if you wanted to commit
suicide she can just jump off those
shoes she doesn't need a building are
you following me just jump off those
shoes and she's dead the things are so
high
so I ask God are you with me I'm the
Lord will direct you he'll speak to your
conscience
all right God bless you